مع صعود نجم حاكم فلوريدا راندي سنتس
كمرشح للرئاسه في عام 2004 24 الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب وجه تهديدا لاذعا
للاخير عبر منصه تروس سوشيال ميديا وحذره
من ان ترشحه يعني انقسام الحزب الجمهوري
وخساره منصب حاكم فلوريدا والرئاسه هجوم
ترامب على منافسه الجمهوريه سبقه بيان
صحفي تطرقت في حمله ترامب الى ما اذا كانت
سيؤيد تغيير قوانين قانون فلوريدا الذي
يتطلب من نواب الولايه الاستقاله اذا
كانوا يترشحون لمنصب فيدرالي واشارت حمله
ترامب الى ان قرار
الاستقاله من الكونغرس في عام 2018 اثناء
الترشح لمنصب حاكم فلوريدا مما يشير الى
انه سيكون من النفاق بالنسبه له ان لا
يفعل الشيء نفسه هذه المره وحتى اللحظه لم
يعلن دي سنه الترشحه من عدمه الا ان مصادر
ذهيل الامريكيه اشارت الى انه كان يستعد
بهدوء بجمع موظفين بعضهم عمل لصالح ترامب
سابقا وتعيين مجموعه مؤيده خارجيه والسفر
طبعا لعده ولايات للتصويت المقبل المبكر
قبيله الانتخابات
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات